that explains it in his mind
this is a cylinder seal made of ivory no
it's bone human
three-headed man-eating Satan common
image from the Middle Ages associated
with the Black Plague amazing Tom Hanks
playing Harvard professor Robert Langdon
in the movie inferno based on Dan
Brown's novel the 2016 movie took in
more than 220 million dollars at the box
offices worldwide Brown is best known
for The Da Vinci Code one of the
best-selling novels of all time his
books have sold more than 200 million
copies around the world
his latest called origin features the
return of symbologist Robert Langdon
this time he's trying to unlock a
discovery that will help answer two
fundamental questions of human existence
where do we come from and where are we
going
Origen has been on the bestseller list
for nearly two months it hit number one
as soon as it went on sale dan Brown is
with us good morning good morning this
is great
Origen that what fifth novel right in
this this Robert Langdon series and it
focuses on this question we talked about
but how God will survive science why did
you choose that topic you know I grew up
in a very religious household my mom was
a church organist I was a religious kid
and my dad was a mathematics teacher
wrote a lot of math textbooks and so I
lived in these two worlds of science and
religion so this is a kind of a
recurring theme in all of these books of
science and religion God and technology
and it's a kind of a personal journey to
try to try to reconcile the two against
each other well my husband was a
theology major but now a restaurateur
but he loves this book and one of the
things too you talk about is artificial
intelligence and where that takes us
that's you delve in it's not only just a
great filler you really kind of
challenge the mind on these artificial
intelligent echnology but AI is
something that fascinates me deeply
mainly because scientists are they can't
agree on whether it's going to save us
or kill us a lot of scientists feel that
we're on the verge of a new renaissance
that AI will solve the big problems of
humanity scarcity overpopulation
pollution and yet a lot of scientists
feel that it's so powerful it will
destroy us and as evidence they remind
us that our species has never created
technology that we have not weaponized
and it would be naive to think that AI
will be any different no you go all-in
Jeff
right Norah's Jeff is right when you
talk about artificial intelligence
because the character Winston was so
good dan I had to keep flipping back to
make sure are we sure this guy is not a
human right he was so real in the way
that he thought and the way that he
behaved what is the message you're
trying to send to us there because after
a while it scared me a little bit that
the guy was so so so clear to me that I
thought I knew him
sure well AI the thing that's going to
make artificial intelligence so powerful
is its ability to learn yeah and the way
I the way AI learns is to look at human
culture everything we do now is
digitized all of our books all of our
podcasts all of our little YouTube
videos our emails so it's possible for a
computer to read all of that
and learn how humans interact and how
they make decisions and the question is
is our culture the best role model for a
new consciousness a new intellect if it
learns to be like we are you know it's
going to learn a lot of compassion but
it could also learn a lot of
self-centered evil throughout all of
your books location has almost become
another character they take place
throughout Europe this one in particular
in Spain what goes in to your location
choice in your research it is a bad to
your book yeah well I mean it first of
all I'm not gonna lie the most fun of
writing these books is saying where am I
gonna write let me go there I spent a
couple years researching Origen and
really the opening scene takes place at
the Guggenheim in Bilbao the spectacular
Museum and these are places that excite
me personally and makes it very easy to
excite a reader about it if I'm
enthusiastic and the funny thing about
the Guggenheim is that Langdon is an art
specialist to class he's a classicist he
knows about Renaissance art I decided I
want to throw him into the world of
modern art mainly because I didn't know
a lot about modern art and I was curious
to learn I had these just hilarious
experiences of trying to appreciate you
know a wheelbarrow filled with jello
yeah and say okay so this is art why is
it art and I will never forget walking
through that museum with the curator and
seeing a giant canvas all white except
for two little blotches of red in the
corner and saying like hey I could have
done that and this man looked at me said
but she didn't yeah and that's when I
started to understand modern art as
concept over artifice
it's more about the idea than the
artifact it's about what are you trying
to take us down in this book cuz I have
to tell you I would read it
nearly every chapter end is on ends on a
cliffhanger like okay I'm only going to
stop there but then it's like never the
next thing begins right four three two
one seconds where do you where are you
trying to take us because it really is
such a ride and everything explained and
everything makes sense in that well
thank you I worked very hard to make
sure there are no loose ends I hate yeah
I like to make sure that all the twists
and turns are explained you know at the
core I'm trying to entertain I'm trying
to make sure that you do turn those
pages and that you have fun reading
these books but there's a second level
where I want to inform about things that
are interesting to me and a lot of these
things I learn as I go modern art for
example the Paul Marion Church
artificial intelligence so my goal is
that that you can't stop turning pages
but at the end of the book you say wow
now I'm curious about the following 37
topics and I need to go read some more
books but Jane you also said something
interesting to me that with religion
were always looking up and in this era
of the smartphone we're always looking
and that was a fascinating thing to talk
to both scientists and theologians while
researching this book and understanding
that technology is changing the way we
interact as humans and you know when I
grow up my miracles were the virgin
birth the resurrection and nowadays you
talk to most kids about the resurrection
and it doesn't really register yeah
their miracles are whatever snapchat can
do this week or whatever the new iOS can
do and it's funny we're talking earlier
about this idea that technology has
given everybody with an iPhone in
international publishing deal instant
instantly right a platform and it used
to be that that there was a vetting
process to information that rose to the
surface you're in the news you
understand that there's no right now
there's no walking down the street
looking up with their phone we are
wonderful in origin is on sale now and
you can hear more CBS this morning on
our podcast find them on our iTunes and
Apple's podcast app